la batalla por la provincia de lugansk
en esta región del donbass continúa en
este día número 80 los bombardeos y los
ataques continúan especialmente en esa
región cercana ávila jurídica y a pesar
de que las fuerzas ucranianas han
logrado detener el avance especialmente
de esos tanques rusos y destruir los
puentes militares que han tratado de
crear las fuerzas rusas pues siguen
habiendo ataques y bombardeos
sin embargo hablando con militares ellos
dicen que están poniendo toda la
posibilidad de la cantidad de tanques y
armamento pesado para defender esta
región es increíble y es que para ellos
es fundamental especialmente por razones
también económicas a que hay grandes
industrias unas de ellas en esta ciudad
de crematorios pero también grandes
minas que son importantísimas para la
economía del país al igual que campos
cultivados sin embargo también nos dicen
que de esta provincia si la mantienen
depende el futuro también de otras
ciudades como ni prosap orilla que
también son estratégicas en la economía
del país especialmente por sus fábricas
dicen que ellos en ningún momento van a
ceder por la pelea por esta región del
donbass porque es estratégica para
mantener a ucrania unida iu a flote